am 8
[Musik]
ganz genau breaking news war jetzt der
erste ministerpräsident droht einen lock
down zu verhängen und zwar für alle ja
weil die bundesweite impfpflicht nicht
umzusetzen sei müsse man schnell handeln
sonst sei ein lock down wie im
vergangenen jahr also für geimpfte und
auch ungeimpfte nicht vermeidbar michael
kretschmer fordert eine sofortiges
bund-länder-treffen er sagt zitat wenn
wir uns zu viel zeit lassen endet dass
wir im vergangenen jahr in einem lock
down es ist wirklich alarm von einer
generellen impfpflicht hält der
cdu-politiker allerdings nichts aus
seiner sicht eine impfpflicht per sie
nicht durchsetzbar uns im studio bild
chefreporter peter tiede und der hygiene
experte dr klaus dieter zastrow peter
zunächst die politische einordnung
kretzschmar cdu ministerpräsident in
sachsen sind immer die bei dienst am
miesesten läuft die dann am lautesten
schreien und es kommt als warnung daher
er warnt davor dass ein lockdown für
alle drohen könnte und das ist natürlich
nicht nur warnung das ist eine
versteckte drohung und er möchte jetzt
quasi von anderen bundesländern mit aus
dem schlamassel gerissen werden und ich
kann es wirklich nicht mehr hören ich
kann es nicht mehr hören dass wieder vor
einem winter ein politiker da steht und
sagt wir müssen jetzt schnell
entscheiden wer du
hast krieg nein es sind die politiker
die entscheiden müssen und die
offensichtlich nicht entschieden haben
am 30 06 im sommer sommer anfang juni
haben die gesundheitsminister der länder
beschlossen sich auf das bus land
vorzubereiten dass man mobile im kings
vorhält dass man das machen muss am
dreißigsten achten haben die
gesundheitsminister der länder
beschlossen was man machen was man
machen muss dass man mit dem bus dann
beginnen muss dass man den impfstoff
bestellen muss und jetzt steht der
kretzschmar und sagt wir müssen schnell
entscheiden entschieden worden ist wie
es ist nichts gemacht worden und das ist
das was ich wirklich fast schon nicht
mehr ertrag und was man den leuten noch
kommen noch zumuten kann die lage in den
krankenhäusern mag schlimm sein die lage
woanders marxismus es mag dringend sein
dass gemustert wird aber warum wird
nicht gewusst hat warum haben wir so
eine eklatante unterschiede zwischen den
bundesländern
die frage die herr kretschmann
beantworten muss ist was heißt bisher
getan was nicht gewirkt hat was können
andere bundesländer jetzt in sachsen tun
damit es bei ihm besser wird warum muss
er uns ein uns allen drohen mit allen
mit einem lockdown wo er doch in sachsen
selbst macht in der hand hat wo die
ministerpräsidenten die
gesundheitsminister alles tun könnten
aber auf sicht aber peter ist das denn
realistisch das ist vielleicht
tatsächlich wieder ein locker und für
alle geben könnte und dass wir
weihnachten wieder getrennt von unseren
familien allein zu hause sitzen eines
stader schnulli natürlich nicht das ist
nicht durch jetzt weiß auch
verfassungsrechtlich nicht durchsetzbar
es ist auch es gab heute morgen gab es
auch eine größere hintergrund runde der
ampel parteien der experten der ampel
parteien zum auslaufen zum ende der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite also der grundlage für
bundesweite maßnahmen einheitliche
maßnahmen das wird auslaufen und wenn
dann gibt es ein gibt einen lock down
für ungeimpfte oder eine art london für
ungeübte einschränkungen für die aber
noch nicht für alle und es ist schlicht
und ergreifend purer populismus jetzt so
aufzutreten da möchte jemand die
alarmglocken schellen es gibt wirklich
not lang darüber müssen wir überhaupt
nicht reden aber einen login für alle
ist kompletter schnulli castro ihre
einschätzung aus ärztlicher sicht ja ich
sehe das ganz genauso ein lockdown jetzt
wo wir praktisch zwei drittel oder
vielleicht sogar drei viertel der
bevölkerung und ich sage es bis sie
vollständig geimpft haben
wenn einem dann nichts weiter ein feld
das ist schon bitter und warum man die
maßnahmen die uns bisher erfolgreich
begleitet haben nämlich die maske zum
beispiel aufzusetzen dann kommt nichts
raus fliegt durch die gegend also und
dann stattdessen in denen den locker und
dagegenzuhalten für alle mal das ist ein
skandal geradezu der gedanke trotzdem
müssen wir natürlich auf die aktuellen
zahlen auch noch mal schauen heute
neuinfektionen das ist der pike 37.000
über 37.000 neue corona kranke wie kommt
das zustande die zahlen sind einfach
nicht vernünftig beleuchtet und nicht
analysiert was natürlich auch in der
kürze der zeit nicht immer gelingt wir
müssen mal sehen was sind das für leute
die jetzt als crooner positiv so sind
sie sind ja keine erkrankung synchrone
positive
entdeckt worden
und manche haben überhaupt gar keine
symptome
irgendeiner hat schnupfen nach der arzt
wir machen mal abstriche und sagt dah
krone wie fühlen sie sich da fühle mich
gut der geht aber trotzdem in die
statistik ein das musste auch
interessiert was sind oder sie welche
leute sind tatsächlich krank und auch
dass die krankenhäuser über sorry kann
ich nicht bestätigen ja und ich habe den
überblick über nur zehn krankenhäuser
mit jeweils zwei intensivstationen da
läuft gar nichts über und ich hatte
gestern mit dem vorstand des prozesses
in einer riesigen krankenkasse
gesprochen und der sagt die bilder aus
leichter sagt er kennt auch keine
intensivstation die natürlich alle
gedacht dass wir nie wieder auf so eine
enorme zahl kommen naja es ist die frage
was eigentlich gezählt wird dass das ist
völlig unklar und
jedenfalls und laden ab juli des jahres
hat wurde er gesagt auch jeder
verdachtsfall gemeldet wird ein
verdachtsfall ist verdacht aber sonst
auch nicht wird er 13 uhr soll jens
spahn eine pressekonferenz geben zum
thema boostern soweit wir wissen was da
zu erwarten ja er wird noch mal die
alarm geschlagen wird nochmal
appellieren dass auch die ärzte obwohl
erst noch keine stiko empfehlung für
alle gibt also ständige impfkommission
empfiehlt was geimpft werden sollen oder
wer geimpft werden soll in deutschland
es gibt noch nicht die stiko empfehlung
fürs booster für alle sondern nur für
bestimmte gruppen für alte für über
70-jährige und für immun- und für leute
mit einer immunschwäche und damit herr
spahn appellieren das sieht dass die
ärzte dessen jeder klassenerhalt
trotzdem impfen das ist auch gar kein
problem weil man muss sich nicht nur
nach der stiko empfehlungen richten man
kann auch so impfen und die stiko
braucht naturgemäß immer etwas länger
als ein expertengremium das kreis dann
erstmal das gute studien an und
empfiehlt dann später eine eine impfung
aber die ärzte können schon vorher
impfen ersparen hat das ähnlich schon
mal diese woche gemacht auf einer
pressekonferenz mit dem rkw chef mit
professor wieder zusammen und das wird
er wieder machen und er wird auch
nochmal an die länder appellieren
endlich tätig zu werden wie gesagt von
drei monaten haben die länder
beschlossen mobil in fünf teams
vorzuhalten impfstoffe rechtzeitig zu
bestellen und mit dem boostern in den
altenheimen zu begehen und was sehen wir
jetzt wir haben wieder ein problem in
den altenheimen wir haben immer noch ein
flickenteppich wir haben bundesländer
die keine tests pflicht für besucher in
den altenheimen oder für pfleger wir
haben bundesländer die das anders haben
wir sehen bundesländer wie das saarland
die in den altenheimen fleißig boostern
wir sehen bundesländer die
hinterherhinken wie zb brandenburg oder
wie niedersachsen und da wird der
appellieren an die länder und an die
ärzte endlich gas zu geben endlich etwas
zu tun es kann nicht sein dass wir
wieder wie im vergangenen jahr das
hätten die schafe haben und dass wir
wieder sehen dass in den altenheimen
versagt wird das da der schutz nicht da
ist dass die ärzte wieder in der hängen
und das ärzte patienten nach hause
schicken und sagen bei ihnen fehlen
jetzt noch zwei wochen an den sechs
monaten die empfohlen sind also sechs
monate nach der vollständigen impfung
noch mal boostern bei ihnen fehlende
zwei wochen oder wie drei wochen es kann
nicht sein dass die leute dann nach
hause schicken dass da wirklich in eine
verunsicherung durch die bundesländer
und die erste entsteht da wird er die
alarmglocken läuten und der wirt
appellieren eindringt wird so eine
booster impfung eigentlich bezahlt auch
wenn ich jetzt noch gar nicht dran bin
wie gut also impfen ist in deutschland
also cola ist sind es in deutschland
kostenlos und dran sein ist also du
kannst sagen wir mal so locker nach fünf
monaten fünfeinhalb monaten kannst du
kannst du hingehen dann kriegst du deine
booster impfung und es wird empfohlen
und herr sparen möchte die booster
impfung jetzt für alle haben einfach
ergreifen weil die not da ist weil man
sieht dass mir im durchbrüche kommen und
das bei bestimmten leuten vor allem bei
älteren leuten und bei leuten mit einer
schwäche der impfschutz nachlässt wie
gesagt nach lässt er ist nach wie vor da
und die schweren fälle die man sieht die
berichte von den intensivstation aus den
krankenhäusern von doppelt geimpften die
mit die schwere verläufe haben das sind
in aller regel leute mit schwersten
vorerkrankungen die haben das beispiel
tony marshall gehabt haben ja auch groß
darüber berichtet tony marshall der im
krankenhaus lag obwohl auf der
intensivstation lag obwohl er doppelt
geimpft war der mann ist dialysepatient
er ist also schwerst vorgeschädigt die
leute trifft ist es trifft nicht otto
normalbürger es trifft mich es trifft
nicht herrn zastrow jetzt mit den
schweren impf durch mit den schweren
durchbrüchen deswegen an die alten ran
und andy immunschwachen zuerst ich
möchte noch ihre frage beantworten
bezüglich wer zahlt das alle öffentlich
empfohlenen impfungen sprich von der
stiko alle impfungen die zum nutzen der
volksgesundheit sondern stiko empfohlen
werden auch von den krankenkassen
bezahlt jetzt hast du nun ist auch im
gespräch
die kostenlosen tests wieder einzuführen
sind vor drei wochen abgeschafft worden
um druck auf ungeimpfte auszuüben hat
sich gezeigt dass hat nicht funktioniert
das haben nicht deshalb nicht mehr
ungeimpfte impfen lassen um eben
sozusagen die kosten zu vermeiden
selbst grünen chef robert habeck hat
gerade gestern gefordert die kostenlosen
tests wieder einzuführen wäre das
sinnvoll ja auf jeden fall wäre das
sinnvoll weil wir natürlich auch leute
dabei haben die die vernünftigerweise
und voller sorge impfen lassen und dann
auch richtig reagieren und zu den kosten
muss man nochmals es geht ja darum dass
gesagt wurde warum sollen die die
vernünftig sind und gesund sind die
kosten für die mit rahm so ein test
kostet im einkauf teilweise unter einem
euro wenn der natürlich für 20 oder 30
euro irgendwo verhökert würde anders
kann man das nicht sagen dann stimmt da
was sehe ich arbeite auch da muss die
politik eingreifen und sagen hier wählen
entweder organisch ja bei den 700
milliarden die wir schon ausgegeben
haben ist das eine sinnvolle maßnahme
aber es wäre natürlich auch wucherpreise
abgenommen bei diesen bei diesen tests
sinnvoll auch weil es ja eben im
durchbrüche gab und auch geimpfte sich
natürlich noch testen lassen können
vielen dank für ihren besuch im studio
das trophy lang peter thiede